schreckliches bahnunglück in
niederbayern zwei brüder 13 und 17 jahre
alt wollten den bahnhof brugg die gleise
überqueren
dabei wurden sie vom regionalzug
richtung münchen erfasst und getötet die
bahnschranken waren bereits unten und
100 einsatzkräfte waren vor ort
die zugstrecke wurde für mehrere stunden
komplett gesperrt
laut polizei wollte der zugführer noch
die notbremsung einleiten aber es war
bereits zu spät
es ist immer schwieriger einsatz
belasten der einsatz die auch die
einsätze wenn menschen ums leben kommen
oder hier 13 und 17 jährige junge
burschen
es sind entsprechende
betreuungsmaßnahmen uhr vor ort in die
wege geleitet worden
für die pendler für schüler die das
ganze ja auch beobachtet haben wollen
kriseninterventionsteam und seelsorger
et cetera auch vor ort um die
betreuungsmaßnahmen aber auch der
angehörigen die dann später zu und
verletzlichkeit gekommen sind zu
gewährleisten
blumen werden niedergelegt und kerzen
angezündet menschen versammeln sich an
der unglücksstelle
sie trauern um die beiden jugendlichen
die an diesem tag ihr leben verloren und
bild reporter karl heim ist für uns in
bruckberg hallo hier ist schon den
ganzen tag für uns hat auch mit der
familie der jungs gesprochen
wie konnte es jetzt zu diesem tragischen
zugunfall kommen ja ich konnte heute
länger mit dem onkel der beiden sprechen
mit dem bruder der mutter der beiden
der hat mir gesagt ja die waren heute
morgen so ein bisschen spät dran dann
hat die mutter dreier söhne zum zum
bahnhof gefahren darunter der 30-jährige
ferien und der 17 jährige hassan o der
mittlere bruder der hat diese diesen
hier das unglück ganz gut überstanden
der steht natürlich jetzt unter schock
aber wurde nicht erfasst von der bahn
seine beiden brüder der sein jüngerer
bruder und sein älterer bruder die haben
dann noch versuchte an den geschlossenen
bahnschranken vorbeizukommen an den zug
der bereits im bahnhof stand und der sie
dann nach landshut zur schule bringen
sollte ja wirklich tragische details die
du uns da schildert der ganze ort wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich unter schock stehen
wie gehen die einwohnern auch mitschüler
jetzt mit diesem und
um genau hier in bruckberg bei landshut
leben rund 5500 menschen
der ort steht total unter schock hier
kommen im minuten-takt man kann es
hinter mir sehen
da ist nämlich die die unglücksstelle
dieser bahnübergang dort stehen seit
stunden über dutzende menschen das waren
jetzt über den tag verteilt mehrere
hundert die jetzt hier immer dann kerzen
blumen und auch bilder der beiden toten
brüder jetzt an der unfallstelle
niedergelegt haben
ich konnte natürlich mit dem onkel
sprechen der hat mir gesagt der mutter
da gibt es natürlich wie sollte es
anders sein
sehr sehr schlecht sie sei nicht
ansprechbar und wird jetzt von einem
kriseninterventionsteam betreut wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren